I have breast cancer that has metastasized to the bones by tumor markers are going down.
Can you explain how this relates to the body metastasis?
Well, typically if your tumor markers are going down, that's typically an indication that your cancer is called me down that you're not getting as much growth.
It's not a perfect representation, but it is one side that we're moving in the right direction.
So does the decreased tumor markers have anything to do with the regression of bones?
So it doesn't have anything to do whether your bones are healing.
How much damage you have in your bones, but it has to do it.
The cancer is cancer growth is decreasing, but you do have to it's like any other test, it's just one test. So you have to weigh that with other tests.
So the number one test for with metastasis would be a PET scan and a CT scan.
So, you know, you'd want to look at that also look at alkaline phosphatase that we talked about alcohol and phosphatase.
Last week, and I said, you know, alcohol and phosphatase, that's one test that you'd have done with a complete metabolic panel.
That's typically considered a liver marker.
But it will be elevated with a body metastasis because you'll get a lytic attack on the bolted, break out of the bolted that will elevate alkaline phosphatase.
So it elevates with metastasis to bold. So let's say you didn't know you had any metastasis to bolted your alkaline phosphatase was elevated, you want to at least can look at that.
Number one reason why alkaline phosphatase will be elevated is not multi metastasis. It's liver congestion and the number one reason for that is a reaction to medication.
So even a healthy medication that might be killing your cancer certainly is congested your liver.
And certainly can be the is still the number one cause that elevated liver markers.
First, AST, ALT and elephant phosphatase.